[Musique]
je peux pas faire ça
l'institution française madame
l'éducation nationale
mais malheureusement elle est à nos
côtés je vous promets je m'en occupe
bien si elle est malade je m'excuse
n'hésitez pas à envoyer votre note de
frais médecin à Virgin Radio
mettre en avant les bijoux exactement
ils sont très beaux d'ailleurs et ça
c'est
notre créatrice Kika prête qui est là
qui est pas là ce soir mais qu'on
embrasse très fort et qui fait le
travail remarquable absolument et tu
peux m'expliquer pourquoi les nounours
ou pas
[Musique]
bonjour ça va
par le vigile des Ardentes alors que
c'est le prochain artiste à passer sur
scène
son self contrôle les légendaires et il
a fini par rentrer